This gluten away a good supplement to reduce gluten. So these I don't familiar with gluten away,
but these products like that, these these gluten and dairy reducing supplements, they're not
to reduce gluten. There if you if you're going, if you're on a gluten-free diet or a dairy-free diet
and you're eating out and they tell you it's gluten-free but you're afraid that you could get
cross-contamination and you're trying to reduce it. These are enzymes. So these products like gluten
away or gluten-zime or gluten-zime is the U.S. enzyme one. We have three or four different
brands that have it. All they are is gluten enzymes. They're enzymes that will help break down gluten.
It doesn't give you a carpluged eat gluten and then you take one of these and it's going to be okay.
No, it doesn't work that way. Do any of these type of supplements rid your body of excess gluten?
No, none of them do. So it's just going to help reduce breakdown any hidden gluten that you might
have got from eating that meal. So we have we have multiple of these orthomolecular,
we can be kidding orthomolecular on our site anymore. They have a DG
enzyme or something like that for dairy gluten. It's enzymes for dairy gluten.
U.S. enzymes has a gluten-zime. That's a real good one. Apex has one. There's multiple.
The science for health has has an aller-zime that's got dairy, it's enzyme for dairy and gluten.